it's always heartbreaking to discover
that the actors who played your favorite
characters have passed away adding to
our first list that you can find at our
YouTube channel these actors have also
moved on without much public fanfare it
doesn't matter whether these actors were
Hollywood royalty they help portray
characters we'll never forget
Richard bone he'll while you might not
recognize Richard Bowen Hills face
you'll recognize some of the characters
he's played over the years especially if
you're a star Wars fan bone hills
history as a competitive fencer and
swordsmanship coach landed him work on
Highlander Flash Gordon and Doctor Who
he also played a variety of characters
in the Empire Strikes Back and Return of
the Jedi the most part he filled various
background roles including multiple
storm troopers and Rebel Alliance
soldiers you'd probably best recognize
him as nine none
Lando Calrissian alien co-pilot during
the attack on the second Death Star bone
he'll passed away on February 4th 2015
at the age of 67 Earl Hindman Earl
Hindman had a relatively low profile
show business career appearing in movies
like Silverado and the Taking of Pelham
one two three
throughout the 70s and 80s he starred as
Bob Reed more than 450 episodes of
Ryan's Hope most 90s kids will remember
him as Wilson the mysterious but
friendly neighbor of the Taylor's on the
hit sitcom home improvement Hyneman died
on December 29th 2003 at the age of 61
due to lung cancer Bernie Mac one of the
original Kings of Comedy Bernie Mac
built his career with a stand-up routine
heavily influenced by Richard Pryor many
might recognize Mac as Ice Cube's
neighbor pastor clever in Friday Mac
went on to star in Charlie's Angels full
throttle Ocean's eleven and transformers
before headlining his own sitcom the
Bernie Mac show during the last years of
his life Mac suffered from sarcoidosis
which heavily affected his lungs he
succumbed to pneumonia complications in
August 2008 at the age of 50 richard
attenborough long before he founded an
ill-fated amusement park using the
secrets of Dino DNA Richard Attenborough
was already an accomplished an
award-winning actor adam burrow starred
alongside Steve McQueen in The Great
Escape he also won two consecutive
Golden Globe Awards in 1967 and 1968 for
his work in the sand pebbles and dr.
Dolittle younger filmgoers will never
forget Attenborough as John Hammond
whose ambitions led to the creation of
Jurassic Park but that's just one short
chapter in a life that ended in August
of 2014 at the age
ninety after many great cinematic
achievements on both sides of the camera
sage Stallone Rocky five is arguably the
least loved film of the iconic boxing
series but under its cheesier elements
there's still a solid story about the
champ going broke losing his ability to
box and nearly losing his relationship
with his son Sylvester Stallone brought
his own 14 year old son sage to play the
part of Rocky jr. in the film after
college sage continued working in small
low-key film projects unfortunately sage
died in 2012 at a young age of 36 due to
a heart attack brought on by coronary
artery disease Chris Penn the younger
brother of veteran actor Sean Penn Chris
Penn followed in the siblings footsteps
breaking into Hollywood at the tender
age of 12 Penn is best remembered for
his portrayal of mob sy and nice guy
Eddie and Reservoir Dogs he also
appeared in Footloose rush hour Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang and grand theft auto san
andreas he died on January 24th 2006 at
the age of 40 Duty cardiomyopathy with
morphine valium marijuana and codeine
all found in his body Sean Penn
attributes Chris's debt to the weight he
visibly gained during the 90s richard
griffiths a veteran stage film and
television actor richard griffiths is
known most versed portrayal of Harry
Potter's awful uncle Vernon Dursley
outside of the Harry Potter series
Griffiths won a slew of awards for his
portrayal of English teacher Douglas
Hector in a play called The History Boys
he also starred in a variety of projects
including Superman - Gandhi Sleepy
Hollow King Ralph and Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy
Griffiths passed away at 65 on March
28th 2013 due to complications shortly
after having heart surgery James Avery
whether you call him the big guy or
Uncle Phil James Avery became a
household name through his portrayal of
Philip banks on The Fresh Prince of
bel-air the burly actor had plenty of
small roles throughout his TV career but
was also known for his voice acting work
he was the voice of war machine on Iron
Man and shredder on Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles what is it Avery also did voices
for the Prince of Egypt the Real
Ghostbusters Fist of the North Star and
Hulk Hogan's Rock and wrestling like
Richard Griffiths Avery died from
complications following heart surgery in
2013 at the age of 68 thank you for
always being a stern funny and loving
father figure on TV I'll fulfill Lou
albano and Daniel
captain Lou albano and Danny Wells
entertained millions of children from
1989 to 1991 on the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show the program featured Nintendo
cartoons bookended by Alabama and Welles
playing the two beloved brothers during
live-action sequences of their Brooklyn
residents albano and Welles also voiced
the animated versions of Mario Luigi in
the same show
captain Liu was a WWE Hall of Fame
member with a prominent professional
wrestling career that started in 1953
and ended in 1995 albano died in October
14 2009 from a heart attack at the age
of 76 he left behind a wrestling legacy
that included one of his grand nephews
former MMA / UFC fighter and
professional wrestler Phil Baroni Danny
Wells who played Luigi was best known
for his TV guest appearances in the
likes of The Jeffersons Happy Days Punky
Brewster
chips and the a-team he also did voice
acting for Heathcliff Batman the
Animated Series and much more
he died of undisclosed causes on
November 28th 2013 richard harris yet
another major lost the cast of a harry
potter series
richard harris played Albus Dumbledore
in The Sorcerer's Stone and the Chamber
of Secrets outside of Hogwarts Harris
was also an accomplished singer actor
director writer producer and songwriter
Harris won Grammy and Golden Globe
Awards for his work on 15 different
albums and more than 70 films including
Camelot the Guns of Navarone Gulliver's
Travels Patriot Games Unforgiven
gladiator and The Count of Monte Cristo
after being diagnosed with Hodgkin's
disease Harris died on October 25th 2002
at the age of 72 thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which actress you want the world to
remember